a new study just came out and it found
that schoolchildren are using Donald
Trump's words to bully other children in
fact at my kids school I overheard one
little boy call another kid the mayor of
London
that's what he actually said yeah the
kids crying I don't know you are too
you're the mayor of London yeah pretty
rough it was true they did find that
kids are bullying each other now with
Donald Trump's words yeah the good news
is most kids outgrow traumas to
vocabulary by the time they're 11
[Applause]
he stole my hair I didn't steal his name
a new report came out and it says that
Donald Trump once shifted charitable
donations for sick kids into his own
business
yes yeah Trump referred to the charity
as the take a Wish Foundation was how it
works just paper to me alleged I mean
after 14 years after 14 years the CEO of
j.crew is stepping down yeah yeah he
said he wants to take a gap year
the show is free what do you want that's
pretty good you're like oh I don't know
about that but you're gonna tell your
parents that one write that coding
funny--i Jie your parents a prospector
vice president Mike Pence's wife karen
has set up a hive of 15,000 bees at
their residence yeah 15,000 bees yeah
meanwhile Mike Pence said he won't be
alone with the queen bee without a
chaperone near that [ __ ] astronomers
are saying that a mysterious signal from
space was caused by gas surrounding a
comment yeah of course the comet is
claiming the gas came from its dog sorry
it shows free here's a proposed bill in
New York that would allow medical
marijuana to be prescribed for menstrual
cramps
yeah yeah which is why millions of men
in New York are now saying it is my time
of the month I this crowd really excited
by that story yeah
we're in Los Angeles I don't know how
that helps them but right maybe all flew
in on one plane the owner of the world's
largest private collection of Star Wars
memorabilia says someone stole two
hundred thousand dollars worth of his
collectibles yeah on the plus side the
collectors reporting that his virginity
is still in mint condition
still in the original box it's a
wrapping still on the Holden I probably
went too far and I apologize won't
happen again
you